[Music]
ed
is with us in tampa hi ed welcome to the
dave ramsey show
hey dave hey chris how are you guys
great man how can we help
well my question is um i have not been
able to work since
uh the covey came along um and my wife
has not missed a day
she got a promotion to uh kind of like
um
in charge of the whole department and
she's gonna get a twenty thousand dollar
a year raise starting in january
um we finished baby step three wonderful
and
and jack thank you and in january we're
gonna
talk to a smart dresser pro now beth is
gonna have to
um do like a lot of traveling and she's
gonna be working long hours
um and she she
says she she would like me to just stay
home um
you know take care of the dogs when
she's out of town you know take care of
the
yard the house um just take care because
you know she's going to come home and
she's not going to want to make dinner
and do all these things
pardon me stay home to take care of the
dogs
no no no there's no kids no kids
no grown okay yeah
what is she making well she went from uh
48 to 68.
and i have not been able to work i've
got um
uh i'm one of those high-risk people
with the colleague
and my doctor told me that i really need
to take this
stay-at-home thing seriously you're
irrita you you've got what kind of a
problem medically
upper respiratory upper respiratory okay
yeah
so and but even when our plan was
i am 60. okay all right
um i was planning on going back to work
once the vaccines were available
but we've still been able to save you
know about a thousand dollars a month
um putting it in the bank
and she's going to get this big bump
into her raise with her
mouth she gets whether there's somebody
at home to watch the dogs or not
so do you think it's a bad decision well
i don't understand it
is what i'm saying that's why i'm being
sarcastic it it there's
um i mean if you are now what now
there's a couple of
caveats i do understand you're not
working if you have a health concern
with upper respiratory and covet i sure
no trouble
but that may be let's just call that um
let's just reach out there and say a
year from now for whatever reason
vaccine or whatever other reason that
that's no longer a concern you are a 61
year old man and your job is to sit at
home and watch the house
yeah i know i know that's just weird
plus i feel really guilty you know
i'm not i'm not trying to kill you it's
just strange
i've always worked you know i've never
been unemployed in my life right well ed
here's the thing buddy i
i think you know you being conscious of
your health situation i think is one
thing
uh but you have opportunities to be able
to work from home
you've got opportunities to be able to
do things where you're not encountering
other people
so i don't think you just throw in the
towel because your wife got a 20 000
raise and if that's what her thought is
i want to suggest you sit down and
and really kind of speak yours your
thoughts your feelings
to make sure you guys are getting on the
same page all of this is the other side
of a health concern
okay if there's a health concern right
we're sitting down you're on the bench
okay
i got no issue with that at all but the
other side of a health concern there's
just great dignity and work
there's not much dignity in watching the
dogs there's just not
i mean they go out twice a day and you
feed them i mean there's just not a lot
to do here so
um you know it's uh uh
no i think i think if i it's going to be
good for your
mental health regardless of your bank
account for you to be
doing something as soon as you're
medically
able to do so with wisdom right and um
so no most the time i hear honestly when
something like this comes up there's
kids at home
and she's making 680 000 right not 68
thousand yeah no there's a zero in a
comma
and and then she wants to you know then
she wants you to stay home and take care
of business because she's out there
killing it right
okay we can talk about that but dude 68
000 bucks
well here's the other side of this coin
too dave he said she's going to be
traveling a lot
so that means he's not going to see her
and so he needs to have something to
yeah to pour into so ed listen sit down
have a conversation
uh you guys talk and if you can't get
agreement you might need to reach out
and get with a marriage counselor
to help you guys kind of navigate this
and and make a long-term decision